imagine que você acabou de chegar em
casa e o chão da sala está encharcado
alagado de água
o tapete já está submerso
os pés dos móveis de madeira já estão
inchando
do alto o bastante o gato está
desesperado tentando entender o que está
acontecendo
você lembra que quando saiu de casa mais
cedo a torneira da cozinha parecia um
pouco mais empenhado do que de costume
você vai até a cozinha tentar entender o
que está acontecendo e constata o
estrago a torneira está jorrando alguma
coisa obstruiu ralar água não desceu
agora você tem este mini dilúvio para
dar conta no seu apartamento
quero saber porque é que vocês fazem
primeiro vocês fecham a torneira ou
vocês enxugar o chão respondeu gente
senão não consegue oi alguém chouchou o
primeiro trecho chora pode ser também
tava lendo essa metáfora deliciosa eu
encontrei no livro a história das coisas
de ana leonard e assim como vocês
mostraram por mais lógico e racional que
seja é qualquer pessoa numa situação
como essa primeiro fecharem a torneira
depois estancar o vazamento depois de
lixo do chão eu vou usar essa metáfora
para mostrar pra vocês como enquanto a
sociedade a gente tem feito exatamente
contrário a gente está deixando a
torneira do consumo jorrar
estamos tentando enxugar o chão do jeito
que dá
hoje a indústria da moda é o segmento
mais bem sucedido em nos convencer a
comprar coisas que a gente não precisa
por isso vou usar exemplos da moda para
falar sobre isso com vocês mas esse é o
raciocínio que se aplica a quase tudo
certo
então vamos lá fazer de conta que a água
no chão da nossa sala é lixo lixo não
vamos a uma palavra melhor fazer de
conta que a água no chão da nossa sala é
revivido resíduo texto que é o resíduo
proveniente da indústria da moda tem
noção do tanto de resíduo teste o que a
gente tem que lidar com nosso planeta
eu vou falar pra vocês a gente
desperdiça na forma de resíduo o
equivalente a um caminhão de tecido por
segundo
gente de onde vem tanto resíduos deve
estar se perguntando assim como eu me
perguntei quando vi esse dado fui tentar
entender e descobrir que nessa conta aí
entram sobras da produção industrial que
por mais bem sucedida que seja a forma
como as nossas roupas são feitas sempre
sobra algo que fica em torno de 20 a 30
por cento do material bruto do material
que levou as nossas roupas é contabiliza
e também as roupas que estão paradas nos
estoques das lojas
sim porque a gente tem roupa que é
produzida e não é sequer vendida fica
parada no estoque da loja mesmo depois
das famigeradas liquidações que aquele
momento que vocês já devem saber que a
gente descobre que aquela roupa que
comprou por quase 200 reais
ganhou o epíteto de 1990 né e aí vida
que segue
mesmo depois das liquidações muitas
roupas ficam pararam nos estoques das
lojas e acontece o que se segue para os
aterros sanitários ou acabam sendo
incinerados em caso de incineração essa
queima libera na atmosfera e
consequentemente pros nossos pulmões
todas as toxinas presentes nas peças ea
gente não pode deixar de contabilizar as
voltas que estão paradas nos nossos
guarda roupas
sim porque embora a produção industrial
de peças de moda diz para olhos vistos
nós nunca usamos tão pouco as roupas que
temos seja porque esse atual modo de
produção industrial privilegia a fonte
em vez de qualidade seja porque a gente
criou mitos maluco sobre sua roupa
chique e não pode repetir roupa na festa
não pode postar a mesma roupa no
instagram para justificar que a gente
tenha essa excelente dispensas guardadas
trancadas sem uso tendo armário
contabilizado todo esse prejuízo é
equivale a aproximadamente 500 bilhões
de dólares por ano agora sim
esses dados foram levantados pela
fundação helen marcado excesso de lixo é
apenas uma das consequências do nosso
atual estilo de vida baseado em
consultas
nós compramos demais
compramos porque precisamos é bem
verdade mas também compramos porque
estamos tristes e vamos nova o timbu
shop parecer ou compramos porque estamos
muito felizes e aí vamos no shopping
comemorar
compramos porque queremos demonstrar
afeto por alguém vamos comprar um
presente ou compramos porque queremos
nos sentir importantes e compramos algo
que dá status principalmente compramos
porque achamos que precisamos de um novo
roupas celulares televisores automóveis
no rastro de cada ato de consumo restam
lixo emissão de gases poluentes na
atmosfera poluição de mananciais de água
doce e justiça social
mas aí que essa crise socioambiental
inaugurou um novo estilo de consumo é é
uma compra fab que a gente faz para
ajudar a salvar um do assistente kit com
a natureza daquela sensação zinha boa
que está fazendo a nossa parte ea gente
até popularizou a expressão para se
referir a esse tipo de consumo é o tal
consumo consciente
gente eu tenho um real problema com essa
expressão
eu não sei se vocês sentem isso
mas eu tenho a impressão de que onde
quer que eu vá hoje estão à venda
canudos de bambu de vidro de nox para
suco para sheik para brink por água de
coco e publicidade deles é tão linda que
dá vontade de comprar um de cada época
vai que você precisa a qualquer momento
de um canudo e assim como aconteceu com
os canudos coisas como ecobags aqui
tirar o lixo copos é de silicone ou de
plástico rígido coisas que foram criadas
para fazer com que a gente reduzisse o
consumo de descartáveis se transformaram
diferente em itens de coleção e cada vez
que alguém me fala que vai comprar
alguma coisa para proteger a natureza ou
para solucionar um problema sócio
ambiental hoje eu juro
eu tenho vontade de abraçar essa pessoa
e dizer assim o colega o consumo
consciente não vai salvar o mundo não
comprar mais coisas que a gente não
precisa é exatamente o oposto do que a
gente precisa fazer número
porque quem tem que ter consciência são
as pessoas e não o consumo sério
será que a gente insiste em se tratar
como consumidores quando obviamente nós
somos muito mais do que isso só pode ser
porque a gente hiper valoriza as nossas
atividades de consumo coisa que não
devia acontecer uma vez por ano por
exemplo acontece a tal da black friday
que é tipo natal só que sem o feriado
sem as comidas gostosas tem os valores
religiosos por trás apenas mais um dia
para a gente comprar coisas que a gente
não precisa pensar que tem gente que
passa uma madrugada na fila e sim de
vida por causa disso segundo que
consciência apenas não muda
comportamento
isso parece o oposto
eu falei nesse momento anterior na lama
anterior mas sempre que eu uso essa
palavra consumo consciente eu lembro de
coisas que eu estou consciente que me
fazem mal e eu continuo fazendo
só a consciência ela não é suficiente
para mudar a nossa atitude o que nós
precisamos neste momento é de uma
mudança de atitude com relação a nossos
atos de consumo
a organização das nações unidas ela
sugere pelo menos duas outras palavras
que eu acho muito mais interessante do
que consciente nesse contexto uma
palavra é sustentável que quer dizer que
o nosso consumo precisa ser bom para o
planeta para as pessoas e para uma
economia mais justa
e há outra palavra é responsável que
significa que eu preciso me comprometer
com as consequências nefastas que o meu
consumo gera terceiro gent que a gente
precisa aprender a fazer as perguntas
certas que foi que fez essa roupa quando
essa pessoa recebeu por isso os direitos
trabalhistas delas estavam garantidos
quando a sua marca preferida quando uma
marca de quem você quer comprar te diz é
que ela é consciente o que leco o verde
ou qualquer coisa parecida apenas
pergunte porquê e não segue enquanto ela
não lhe apresentar uma resposta
convincente quarto é que não dá pra
falar de consumo consciente e consciente
quer que seja sem falar de desigualdade
se todo mundo viver se de acordo com o
padrão de consumo acidental lazer
baseado em passeio no shopping para
comprar uma coisa em relaxar um celular
novo a cada 12 anos automóvel
o único planeta não daria conta das
nossas necessidades nome diz é pegada
ecológica ea nossa já supera e muito os
limites do nosso planeta
uma pesquisa da ong wwf diz que nós já
estamos consumindo recursos equivalentes
a 1,7 pelo planeta quase o dobro do que
nós temos estão na média do brasil já é
maior do que a média do mundo nós
consumimos o equivalente a 1,8 planeta
claro
não é nada perto do que os estados
unidos fazem se todos os cidadãos do
mundo consumissem como os estadunidenses
consumem seria necessário cinco planetas
terra para suprir as nossas necessidades
na outra ponta desse espectro da índia
que com mais de um bilhão de habitantes
consome recursos equivalentes a 0,7
planeta
então olha para as questões provocadas
pelo excesso de consumo com
responsabilidade porque a consciência a
gente já viu que apenas não basta
significa encarar que tem uma tremenda
de uma desigualdade e injustiça
acontecendo exatamente agora que a gente
tem um pequeno contingente de pessoas
consumindo muito mais do que a parte que
lhes cabe
enquanto grandes massas da população
estão completamente excluídas das
benesses da nossa sociedade industrial e
não estou falando que todo mundo tem que
ter direito a um celular novo não tô
falando de coisas básicas água potável
segurança alimentar abrir o contra
desastres naturais
tá na hora da gente redistribuir as
benesses da nossa sociedade em favor dos
mais pobres
não eu não tô falando que a gente tem
que chegar em casa pegar o excesso do
guarda-roupa e boa para os pontos
dorr para os pobres virou nosso à dengue
o nosso salvo conduto para consumir mais
e a questão é justamente essa a gente
não precisa de mais gente
o consumo consciente não vai salvar o
mundo
mais um senso mais apurado de justiça
olha eu tenho certeza que tem potencial
para salvar o mundo bem como é que a
gente vai fazer isso mas eu tenho uma
intuição de que um bom começo é a gente
parar de se chamar de consumidores
nós não somos consumidores são os
cidadãos habitando essa mesma nave
planeta terra
a gente se meteu junto dessa encrenca eu
acho que a gente tem condição de sair
mas uma coisa é certa a solução
não vai vir pelo cartão de crédito
enquanto isso a nossa sala está alagada
encharcada de água enquanto isso tem que
chutar fora passando sede o que é que a
gente vai fazer
obrigado
[Aplausos]